[Music]
how do you get from that shell to moving
actual functional art to okay from that
shell to to a functional art - you need
electronics that one's free of
electronics at the at the moment so you
have to put motors motors into the feet
you got to have the sprite speed
controllers and stuff
most of these here run off of a speed
controller that controls the
coordination between the feet and all
the acceleration deceleration and the
brand we're using basically is from
explosive ordnance robots the motors are
really powerful it's the same things you
would see in a battle bot but they're
also used in wheelchair lifts then
there's a motor in the dome that's run
by a small
speed controller like you have in an RC
car and all that has to do is rotate you
know back and forward to make the dome
go tell me how much is one of these
weigh these weigh anywhere from 175 200
pounds and it's like a linebacker yes
and when if it runs into you it's very
severely painful so what's going on up
top in his dome you know what all the
pieces that move the periscope what's
going on in there most of these one of
the nice technologies that we're using
is a slip ring so all the power and all
the signals are housed in the bottom and
they're coming up through a spinning
ring so you can have 12 2014 through and
it twists 360 without ever tangling a
wire so all that's transferred up and
there's all kinds of gadgets the
periscope is is a fun one that lives in
and out which was never on an actual
droid if you see in the movies it only
comes out of the sand or it's hidden in
fog so to have that put on as an
innovation from an X just of the club to
do that you have all the panels that
open Chris is behind you is panels will
do the wave if he pushes a switch to
zero that's really yes and both the
finished ones have fire extinguishers in
them as well awesome and how much would
it cost me to build start up you know
from the beginning it depends on what
you're gonna build away there are
several materials whether you're gonna
do it with styrene wood or aluminum
aluminum let's say I'm going to build
one of these real heavy actual Artoo's
you should expect a budget about 10
grand over a two to three year period
these are $10,000 or two units easily
some of us will come in under that some
of us will go over that it depends on
how innovative of a person you are and
actually the less innovative the
probably the better off you are
what's the like weirdest different to
the non-traditional somebody's built
into one ADR to use mine on the sound
system runs off of my Zune mp3 player
that's pretty so he hacked the docking
station to fit inside so my sounds are
run off of a remote currently eventually
I'll move our two sounds to a different
system but I'll keep the Xun because
he's my home stereo man that's great so
you're kind of stereo it's an art TV -
yeah well thanks so much thank you
really appreciate it